[Music]
what's up y'all it's your boy Langston
Belton I just got out of Marvel's
Spider-Man 2 symbiotic relationships
Paul h-banel my first Hall age panel I'm
still a buzz and still excited all the
things that we saw and I can't wait to
tell you all about it so before the cast
came out before anyone from Insomniac
games came out they hit us with a brand
new story trailer that showed off a ton
of new stuff it's on a new gameplay and
a ton of new details from this highly
anticipated game first of which Harry
Osborne's back that's right no longer
suspended in liquid he's out and about
and reconnecting with Peter Parker and
that kind of adds a little wrinkle
between the Friendship of Peter and
Miles who you know they were best
friends they were spider buddies so we
don't know what's going to happen now
that Harry's back in the mix it also
showed off some awesome awesome gameplay
and of course the trailer finished off
with the game reveal of Venom that's
right my favorite Spider-Man villain one
of the coolest design characters in all
of Marvel them Venom is coming to Marvel
Spider-Man 2 and after the trailer
dropped and our Jaws were on the floor
we had to pick them back up because of
course we had the actual panel itself
and what a star-studded affair it was
let me read some of these names to y'all
we had from Insomniac Games Brian into
heart we had Ryan Smith John Paquette
and Jacinda Chu and they broke down all
of the amazing behind the scenes uh
stuff uh going into really the creation
of this game the evolution of these
characters we started with Brian filling
Us in that this game takes place roughly
nine months after the event of Marvel's
Spider-Man Miles Morales that means that
Peter Parker's I mean he's more
confident his powers he's more confident
in his new partner and also miles is
more confident in his power and his
abilities so they are like this awesome
spider Duo and and joining them of
course is the third piece of the puzzle
Mary Jane Watson and she is rounding out
this little spider Trio of crime with
fighting do-gooders it's really really
awesome but Brian and the entire team
talked mainly about
not just the evolution of these
characters but how they worked together
creatively and the immense
responsibility of bringing these
characters to our video game consoles
and our small screens and also telling a
really compelling story that honors
these characters and honors the love and
passion these people have the people all
these people here at Comic-Con have for
these characters Jacinda Chu the
wonderful amazing jacintochu was a
treasure Trove of details uh talking
about the design elements of Peter miles
and of course Venom we got to see a lot
of really awesome awesome uh concept art
showing off how some of these characters
evolved what they look like in game it
was just every second there was
something else to smile about and laugh
about and flip about and of course they
were joined by the amazing cast of this
game Yuri lowenthal of course playing
Peter Parker AKA Spider-Man Naji Jeter
Miles Morales Laura Bailey MJ and uh
listen for a big horror fan like myself
myself
Tony Todd the legendary actor Tony Todd
was on stage he is the voice of Venom
and they you can tell that they had such
an amazing time making this game they
had an amazing time uh crafting these
characters following their Journey uh
Tony Todd talked about the really
awesome experience of being in the booth
and called it one of his most creatively
rewarding Endeavors in voice over to
date which of course made the roof come
off the place and this cast really
nowadays it's tough to think about
Spider-Man and Miles without hearing the
voices of Yuri lowenthal and Naji Jeter
in your heads and and these two they are
a dynamic duo in real life Yuri
lowenthal of course came out uh in a an
amazing black symbiote suit not an
actual symbiote suit it was like a suit
with jacket and pants he didn't come out
covered in slime or whatever symbiote's
made of but it was awesome and of course
all of these people were joined by VP
and creative director for Marvel games
Bill Roseman and Bill Roseman of course
his passion permeates through the room
and he was so so excited to talk about
the fact that this team has stayed
together even through the pandemic they
still met up and just hung out and
talked about their favorite Spider-Man
stuff uh it was really really cool to
see his excitement and his passion that
you knew was flowing throughout this
entire creative team and of course all
the creative folks back at Insomniac
games now
there was more just when you thought
there couldn't be more they gave us more
because out came the amazing collector's
edition statue that features miles and
Peter fighting Venom in this awesome
Dynamic pose as Spider-Man uh miles and
Peter are above Venom and Venom is
grabbing miles like I can describe it
all day but you can go online and check
out that statue for yourself but of
course that wasn't it because they then
told us that a special edition PS5
console emblazoned with symbiote black
Spider-Man red with that white symbol
and the controller your DualShock
controller is also going to have that uh
symbiote look with the red and stuff
like that it
the sound that came out of people's
bodies when that when that PS5 was
announced and shown on that big screen
it was unlike anything I've ever
experienced we also got some details
about Spider-Man's new black suit that's
going to affect gameplay it's going to
affect traversal and speaking of
traversal web Wings I'm gonna jump
around because there's every time I I
say something new I think of something
else that was awesome so the web wings
were getting the you know you thought
you know you always see inspiring with
those web Wings where they are
functional they're going to allow you to
get to some of those brand new areas
that we also heard about including
Brooklyn and Queens you get to go visit
on May's house this game is going to be
a love letter to the Mythos of
Spider-Man both Peter Parker and Miles
Morales and capping it off with an
amazing Villain Like Venom and oh I
forgot to mention Craven the Hunter and
the lizard are in this game
what what that many villains that much
time were all taken off work everyone in
their new we're all taking off work to
play this game I'm gonna do the same
thing except my work is also talking
about this game so I'm having fun either
way but listen I'm gonna go talk to some
of the Marvel fandom and some folks the
Marvel Booth before we have a signing
here later on with that cast and
creative team uh I'm going to go outside
and and sufficiently lose my marbles
over all the awesome stuff that we had
seen at Marvel Spider-Man 2 symbiotic
relationships panel now if you want to
keep up with all the news and updates
Happening Here on the floor you go to
marvel.com
sdcc and you can keep up with all the
things coming out of Marvel here at San
Diego Comic-Con 2023.